ก็
สวัสดีครับครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูนิสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนเรียนทุกคนครับฮ่าๆวันนี้สบายดี
ไหม
คิดว่าสว่าง
แต่คนนี้จะสังเกตตัวเองหัวเปียก
ทำอะไรมาหัวเปียก
ไปข้างนอกแล้วก็วิ่งกลับมาอาบน้ำ
แล้วก็มาสอนนะคะมาหัวนี้จะมีน้ำอาจจะ
ติดถึงเร็วไม่ก็สอนไปหัวจะฟูๆนะคะ
โอเคอะไรเจ็บหูเจ็บหูฮือเจ็บลงมาที่เนี้ย
อ๋อ
คุณนิคเคยเป็นไหมคิดก็คุณนี้เคยเป็นแค่
เวลาเวลามีน้ำมันต่อไปหนูอัลโลเก็บมันจะ
รู้สึกแบบมันมันก๊าดรำคาญนิดหน่อยเพราะ
ว่าพ่อน้ำมาอยู่ในหูแล้วมันไม่ออกอาเป็น
ตอนนี้น้ำลพ.น้ำเข้าพ่อมึงเข้าแล้วก็นะ
เว้ยเดี๋ยวมันก็ออกแต่มันไม่ออกหรือว่ากู
เอ๋ใช่ขัดกันบัดมากใหม่
คู่เอกขึ้นเคยใช้ Kat  Tun บาทแล้วก็วัน
นึงก็เจ็บแล้วก็ไม่รู้เป็นอะไรไปหาหมอหมอ
ก็บอกว่าอ้ออันนี้ใช้คัตเติ้ลบัตมากไปไม่
ดีมันเหมือนกันดันอะไรเข้าไปเข้าไปคุณหมอ
ต้องดูดออกมาอู้
แต่มันเจ็บแล้วเจ็บเรามาตรงเนี้ยมันก็ไม่
ได้เป็นอะไรก็เลยงงต้องระวังหน้าอีก 5
วันไม่หายไปหาหมอไปหาหมออ๋อครับฮ่าๆๆทำไม
ต้องรอ 5 วันเหอะ
ก็ไม่รู้เหมือนกันนะคะทำไมต้องรอห้างช่าง
มันเหอะอยากจะรอ
เพลงเอกของเอก 5 วันนี้ราคาสบายดีไหมวัน
นี้คุณนิคสบายดีคุณนี้กิมคอตีบ-เช้าอ๋อ
คู๋ก็อิ่มกินข้าวเย็นเออโอเค
กินข้าวเช้าอร่อยไหมคะอร่อยครับเพราะคุณ
นิคทำกับข้าวเอง
อุ้ยทำอะไรก็
อาหารเช้าครับก็มีผักครับก็ผัดผัดแล้วค่ะ
มีไข่ดาวคำเมื่อแต่ก็เก่งอยากข้าวหรือไม่
กินข้าวไม่กินข้าวครับกินกับข้าวจัดก็
จริงๆมีขนมปังครับนายตกถ้าเป็นแผ่นๆ
ประมาณนิ่งชายขาดมือให้ที่จริงดูฟังแล้ว
มันนิดหน่อยนะเนี่ยกูอีกกินเยอะเลยครับ
มื้อเพราะว่า
คุณเล็กจ่ายกินมื้อเช้าไม่เยอะค่ะถ้าอยู่
บ้านวันหยุดก็จะกินมื้อเช้าไม่เยอะแต่ถ้า
ต้องไปทำงาน
จะกินเยอะนิดหน่อยเพราะว่าไม่รู้ว่าจะได้
พักเที่ยงหรือได้หยุดกินข้าวอีกครั้ง
เมื่อไหร่ไม่ฟังแล้วน่ะฟังแล้วน่าสงสาร
จังเลยนะ
เสียงตอนไหนใช่ๆ
งั้นเนี่ยเราเจอกันเนี่ยเราต้องเล่านิทาน
ใช่ไหมคะให้ต้องเล่านิทานครับเรารู้สึก
ว่าแสงของกูเองจะจ้ามากเปิดคอม
อ่ะโอเครถแสงแล้วชัดละโอเค
ขอเล่านิทานวันนี้ครับแต่ก่อนจะเล่านิทาน
เดี๋ยวต้องรู้ก่อนว่าวันนี้วันอะไรวันนี้
วันนี้วันที่ 7 เดือน 7 ขอเลขสวย
วันที่ 7 เดือน 7 นี่ก็
อะไรก็ลดราคาใช่มั้ยๆคู่นี้เห็นอยู่ใน
โทรศัพท์มีข้อความชอบอี Lazada ส่งมาค่ะ
แต่คุณนี้ตัวช้อปปิ้งไม่ได้แล้วเพราะว่า
ไม่ได้อยู่ไทย
ที่อเมริกาได้ไหมเสื้ออเมริกามี Shopping
ครับต่อว่าไม่ใช่ 7 เดือน 7 เพราะว่า
เมื่อ
สุดสัปดาห์ที่แล้วเมื่อวันจันทร์ใช่เขาจะ
เป็น One  in  the  defendant ของ
อเมริกันวันที่ 4 ในวันที่ 4 อันนั้นก็จะ
มีของลดราคามีเยอะมาก
เสรีภาพใช่ Siri ถามเสริม 5 ของคนไป
ช้อปปิ้ง
เมตตา
โอเคๆเอานะปีศาจเป็นเสรีภาพของประเทศ
อเมริกาแต่ถ้า
พอถึง on เสรีภาพคนก็จะบอกเอ๊ยต้อง
ช้อปปิ้งเพราะของรถอายุเยอะมากถ้า
เสรีภาพของมนุษย์เงินเดือน
มนุษย์เงินเดือนจะได้ท็อปปิ้งได้สบายใจนะ
ฮะมันที่ 7 นะคะเดือน
กรกฎาคมวันนี้รัชดานะ
คุณที่เขียนได้สวย
ใช่
ปีกเอี่ยม
ข้อสไตส์นะ
255 เน็ตไหมผู้เข้าชมแล้วเขียนไม่สวย
แล้ว
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ฮ่าๆคุยก็ลุ้นนะคะโอเคเพราะว่าไถใช้เมาส์
ใช่ไหมใช่เหมาเขียนนะคะถ้าปีถ้าเป็นปี
ถ่ายก็
ปีนี้ขอสมออ่ะคุยเขียนให้ไหมลองปิดใช่เมา
ได้ไหมไม่ได้ไม่ได้นะครับอ๋อไม่ใช่ค่ะครู
เอ๋ไปคิดของคุณนิ
ทำไมไม่ต้องคลิกของตัวเองๆโอเค
2022 โห
นะใช้เมาส์เขียนยากจริงๆค่ะนักเรียนการดี
กว่า
โอเคเราวันนี้วันอะไรครับวันที่เจ็ดแต่
เป็นวันอะไรวัน
แต่ถ้าแคร์เขียนให้ค่ะเขียนให้ก็เขียน
แล้วใช่ไหมคะกูเขียนต่อก็ได้นะครับ
กูเอช่วยลุ้น
วันพฤหัสบดีนะคะ
มันคะหรือจะปะดีเติมจุดให้โอเคไม่ใช่
วันพฤหัสบดีวันที่ 7 นะคะวันที่ 7 เดือน 7
เดือน 7  9 กรกฎาคมแล้วก็พี่พ.ศ.
2565 ค่ะครู a เขียนไปแล้วว่าปีคศ 2  022
เนาะใช่ค่ะ
ลายครับแล้ววันนี้คุณนิมีนิทานก่อนนอนมา
เล่าให้ครูฝั่งใช่ไหมใช่ครับครูเอกจะได้
ไปนอนสบายๆ
อุ้ยทำไมคู่นี้ต้องเริ่มต้นที่การักครั้ง
หนึ่งนานมาแล้วนะได้ครับได้จะไม่รู้ว่า
ครูเอกเคยได้ยินไหมนิทานเรื่องนี้แต่
เดี๋ยวครูเอ๋ลองสั่งแล้วก็นึกต่างขับวาย
ค่ะจริงๆกูเอกเข้าฟังนิทานหลายๆเรื่องแต่
เคยฟังน้า
นานมาแล้ว
พร้อมรักครั้งหนึ่งนานมา
นานแหละ
แล้ว
เป็นเด็กมานานแล้วก็ได้บอกนานละมาๆ
อาน่าจะอายุเด็กๆจนถึง 15 เนี่ยเคยฟังนะ
คะเด็กถึง 15 ก็ 30 กว่าปีเนอะ
30 กว่าปี Max  24  10 ปีอ่ะฮ่าๆๆเกือบ
10 ปีโอเค
นานมั้ยนานนานมาแล้ว
งั้นวันนี้จะให้ครูนิเล่าให้ครูฟังนะๆได้
ได้ครับครูเอกครูเอลบไปจุดแดงๆอันนี้ให้
ได้และได้ขอโทษกลับมาทุกข์เป็นไรครับโอเค
ได้ก็วันนี้ครับเรื่องที่คุณนิดจะมาเล่า
ให้ฟังเนี่ยเป็นเรื่องนี้
ขอไม่มีเป็นเราใช่มีเต้นรำ
ไปดูเต้นเราไม่ก่อนเลย
โอเคเดี๋ยวคนเออเดี๋ยวก่อนนะคุณนิคมีภาพ
อยู่ 3 ภาพนะคะในรูปนี้ก็จะมีมินนกเขาพี่
โก้เห็นนะคือมีนกนกอะไรคนนี้นกนะครับอ่า
เราจะเรียกว่านกกระสา
นกกระสาแล้วข้างล่างก็จะมีหมาใช่หมาหรือ
ฆ่าสุภาพหน่อยก็เรียกว่าสุนัขเช้ามี 2
ชื่อนะคะเราเรียกที่ 2 ชื่อหมาโอเคสุนัข
โอเคราคาไปกับสุนัขอันนี้เป็นสุนัขอะไรคะ
สุนัขตัวนี้ครับเป็นสุนัขจิ้งจอกครับ
สุนัขจิ้งจอกค่ะก็จะเรียกกันว่าสุนัข
จิ้งจอกหรือหมาจิ้งจอกค่าคุณนิครู้ไม่คำ
ว่าสุนัขแล้วแปลว่าอะไร
ไม่รู้ครับเท้าสวยอ๋อโอเคโอเคเขาบอกว่า
เขาบอกว่าหมานะเค้าสวยสุนัขก็คือเท้าสวย
โอเคครับอ่ะ
และก็คนในกำลังเช็คไงว่าสวยถ้าผมหมาถ้า
เป็นหมาหรือเป็นหมายที่เราริบที่เรา
เลี้ยงที่บ้านมันก็สวยแหละเพราะว่าเราก็
ทำความสะอาดเนาะแต่ถ้าเป็นหมาจรจัดที่ตาม
ถนนน่ะส่งหน่อยค่ะคะเลขส่งของท้าว
เปรียบเทียบมาสัตว์อย่างอื่นเขาบอกว่า
เท้าสวยเอกอะเหรอ
สวยก็ได้สวยก็สวยครับ
หาโอเคก็เนี่ยครับในเรื่องนี้เนี่ยนิทาน
ก็จะเกี่ยวกับสัตว์สองตัวนี้ถ้า
กับหมาจิ้งจอก
มือชายหั่นครับแล้วก็แล้วก็ยังมีสัตว์
อื่นๆอยู่เป็นเพื่อนด้วยนิดหน่อยสิได้ก็
มีสัตว์อื่นๆอยู่ด้วยครับเพราะว่า 2 ตัว
นี้เขาอยู่ในป่าแล้วมันค่ะมีสัตว์หลาย
ประเภทหลายแบบที่สปาด้วยกันใครในรูปนี้มี
อะไรบ้างคะเนี่ยที่มีหมาจิ้งจอกนกกระสา
เต้นรำ
เราจะเขียนตัวเลขไว้ก่อนตัวที่หนึ่งแล้ว
ก็ตัวที่ 2 ค่ะแต่ที่ 2 หมาจิ้งจอกหรือ
สุนัขจิ้งจอกใจครับอย่างตัวที่ 3 ครับที่
3 อันนี้ก็จะเป็นนกนกทั่วไปนะคะ
ก็จะตัวเล็กกว่านกกระสานกกะแรกขาเขาจะยาว
ค่ะอ่ามีแล้วก็ข้อยาวมีปีกใหญ่คือ
เราก็มีอะไรอีกครับตรงนี้อันนี้มีกระต่าย
ไหมคะได้ครับอันนี้ครับมีกระต่ายอันนี้ก็
กระต่ายเหมือนกันค่ะแล้วก็มีหนูอ่ะโอเค
กระรอกมากรอกครับร้องไม่คุยก็หนูนี่หนู
เหมือนกันจะมีอันนึงอันนี้รอรอครับ
อันนี้นะคะ
อันไหนครับอันนี้อันเนี้ยหนูมั้ยใช่ๆนิด
โบสถ์ที่ 6 อันนี้ก็เป็นหนู
ใช่ครับก็มีทั้งหมด 6 แบบ 6 นิด 6  6 ตู้
6 บริษัท 6 ใหญ่
กบยางครบชนิดครับแต่มีหลายๆตัวค่ะอะไรก็
อันนี้เขาคือการละครั้งหนึ่งนานมาแล้ว
เนี่ยมันหลับละ
นานงาน
นานมากไม่เล่าซะที
อะไร
โอเคไรนานๆแต่ถ้านักเรียนครูและต้องแล้ว
ว่าอยู่ตรงไหน
ก็คือในป่าเนี่ยครับนกกระสาเนี่ยเขาชอบ
เต้นรำอส.
[เพลง]
พี่
ปุ้ยเดี๋ยวคุณเองอายุมากคูเอกก็ไม่เหลือ
ละ
ๆอยู่ตอนเต้นก็สนุกครับแต่พอมันเสร็จแล้ว
นอนตื่นเช้ามาระบบโอ้โอ้โห
เขาบอกว่าต้องซ้ำตรงกว่าๆวันที่ 1 โอ๊ยก็
ต้องวันที่ 2 วันนี้สูงโอ๊ยก็วันที่ 3  4
5 จะไม่โอ๊ยละโรงพยาบาลดอกพยาบาล
ครบ 5 วันก็
ไม่
หา 3 ไปเรื่อยๆก็จะอยู่ตัวก็จะไม่เจ็บค่ะ
คิดว่านะว่าคิดว่าแต่ว่าในนี้ครับก็กูอะ
จะเห็นว่าสารพวกเนี้ยเขาเหมือนกับตกใจใช่
ไหมใช่ครับใช่ก็ตกใจอ่ะทำไมเพราะว่า
สุนัขจิ้งจอกกับเขาเห็นว่านกกระสาเต้นรำ
แล้วอิฐเฉยใช่เพราะสวยแล้วแบบสัตว์หลายๆ
ตัวในนั้นเห็นแล้วคนชอบมาสนุกด้วยใช่ไหม
เจาะเห็นแล้วเขาอิจฉาเพราะว่าเขาว่าอย่า
ให้คนสนใจเขาเหมือนกันสนาค่ะใช่เขาก็เลย
พอเห็นนกกระสาเป็นเนี่ยอยู่ดีๆเขาก็เข้า
ไปเต้นด้วยไปเต้นรำด้วยกันมันก็เลยเป็น
ได้ครับชายแต่ว่าสัตว์ตัวอื่นเขาก็กลัว
ใช่ไหมคะใช่เขากลัวเพราะว่าสุนัขจิ้งจอก
เจ้าเล่ห์คือ
เจ้าเล่ห์ก็คือเหมือนกับเขารู้ว่าสุนัข
จิ้งจอกในชอบทำอะไรแล้วเหมือนกับคิดไม่ดี
เฮ
มีลักษณะสิ้นจอกนี่กินสัตว์ด้วยใช่ไหมใช่
หน้าๆกินสัตว์ตัวเล็กตัวน้อยมันก็ตัดทุก
ตัวเนี่ยเขาก็คิดว่าเองมาเต้นรำด้วยมาทำ
ดีด้วยเนี่ยคิดอะไรหรือเปล่ามันเล่นด้วย
เนี่ยทำเป็นพิษนิคุณนินกกระสานี้คือเขา
เต้นทุกวันใช่ไหมคะด้วยกับมันเป็นทุกวัน
แล้วก็มีเพื่อนๆสัตว์มันเป็นด้วยกันๆครับ
แต่วันนี้สุนัขจิ้งจอกมาแอบเล่น
เธอเด่นได้ยังไงฉันต้องเด่นด้วยๆไงก็เลย
ไปเต้นด้วยแล้วเพราะเต้นตุ๊บวงแถบก็ต้อง
ขอวงแตกคือ
รอกกระต่ายหนูนกที่เป็นอยู่เป็นเพื่อนนก
รักษาแบบตายให้ครัวตกใจก็สุนัขจิ้งจอกมา
ว่ามันจะมากินเราหรือเปล่าเธอเคย
เห็นอันนี้แหละคนนี้เราถึงไปคิดอะไรเลย
ไหมขอบคุณเท่าไหร่ครับกี่สมัยก่อนกูเอกไป
เที่ยวกับเพื่อนๆที่ทำงานทุกคนร้อง
คาราโอเกะโทรคุยเองหยิบไมโครโฟนมาร้อง
คาราโอเกะทุกคนไปนอนหมดเลย
Walker
ตัวเองเหมือนสุนัขนออก
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
เบอร์ก็เลยเข้าไปแล้ววงแตกเลย
ไอ้สงสารใครดีสงสารเพื่อนๆหรือสงสารสุนัข
จิ้งจอก
อันนี้นักเรียนต้องลองคิดดู
ก็เป็นคิดเองนะคะว่าน่าจะสงสารใคร
แล้วเกิดอะไรขึ้นต่อไปคะคนนี้ก็อันนี้
ครับพอเขาเข้าไปเป็นด้วยใช่มั้ยตัวสุนัข
ก็วงแตกแต่ที่เนี้ยะสุนัขจิ้งจอกเขาก็ไม่
สนใจเพราะเขาก็มีความคิดว่าเออมาเต้นกับ
มาเต้นรำกับนกกระสาเราภาษาเนี่ยใครๆก็ชอบ
สัตว์ตัวแต่ก็ชอบเพราะอยากอยู่ใกล้เขาก็
กินมีความคิดว่าแกล้งทำเป็นสนิทกับนก
กระสาอย่างเงื่อนกับนกกระสานถ้าเป็น
เพื่อนสนิทกับนกรักษาสัตว์ตัวอื่นก็จะชอบ
เขามาที่ชอบนกประสานอ๋อหวังผลประโยชน์นาย
ๆถ้าไม่ได้คิดจะเป็นเพื่อนจริงๆไม่ได้
อยากเป็นเพื่อนจริงๆแต่คือทำเหมือนว่า
อยากอยู่กับนกกระสาอยากยืนนักล่าช้าให้คน
อื่นเนี่ยสนใจค่ะ
อาบก็
นี้ก็เหมือนทำเราจะเรียกว่าอะไรแกล้ง
แกล้งเป็นเพราะไม่ใช่แกล้งภาษาไทยและเส
แสร้งเสเเสร้งอ่ะคะแกล้งก็คือแกล้งทำค่ะ
นักเรียนถือว่าถ้าภาษาตรงๆคือเสแสร้งคือ
คือจริงๆไม่ได้ชอบแต่ตัวดีมาอะหมดมันกู
เองจริงๆไม่ชอบคนนึงเลย
ทำไมแล้วอีกเสร็จก็เห็นหน้านิ
สวัสดีค่ะวันนี้ผมสวยจังเลยนะคะอุ้ยน่า
รักจังเลยค่ะกินข้าวแล้วใช่ไหมคะอีกแรง
มากคนนี้ไม่ถึงขายแล้วไม่คุย
เหมือนไหมเสแสร้งเหมือน
นายก็เสแสร้งครับเป็นแบบนี้จะว่านกกระสา
เนี่ยก็ไม่รู้หรอกนกขาเขาก็เออมีเพื่อน
เพิ่มไม่เป็นไรขอแต่ว่านกกระสาจิตใจดีมาก
ครับใช่เขาก็ไม่คิดอะไรอาจไม่เข้าเลขใช่
มั้ยเหมือนสุนัขจิ้งจอก
ขับขี่เข้าใจละและที่นิดแต่ไปในรูปเขาวาด
มาก็หน้าตาเสแสร้งนะเนี่ยให้กับสุนัข
จิ้งจอกอ่ะตาหน้ามันเหมือนกับมีอะไรอยู่
แล้วอ่ะแบบท่าเรือไหนถึงจอดจริงๆแล้วจะ
เรียกเหรอหน้าตาเจ้าเล่ห์ใช่
เหมือนนะเนี่ยจริงๆแล้วคือ a เป็นสุนัข
จิ้งจอกหรือเปล่าการคุณเล็กเป็นนกกระสา
จิ้งจอก
มีเนี่ยพอเขาเศษแป้งว่าอยากเป็นเพื่อนกับ
นกกระสานค่ะเขาก็มีความคิดว่าแบบเฮ้ยหลาย
คนชอบน่ารักใช่มั้ยเขาอะอยากจะทำให้นก
กระสาเนี่ยรู้สึกอาลัยรู้สึกขายขี้หน้า
วันนกกะสาลำแล้วก็สวยทุกคนก็คงโอ๊ยสวยจัง
เลยมีแต่คนชมมีแต่คนชอบเขาอ่ะส่วนสุนัข
ตอบเนี่ยมีความคิดไม่ดีว่าแบบอยากให้รู้
สึกเสียหน้าบ้างเพราะว่าไม่มีใครชอบสุนัข
จิ้งจอกใช่มั้ยเฮ้ยใช่สองโกเล่ครับที่
เนี้ยเขามีความคิดว่า
เอาแบบนี้ดีกว่าเขาจะทำอะไรเขาว่า
เชิญเหมือนกับบอกให้นกกระสาเนี่ยมากิน
ข้าวที่บ้าน
ใจดีๆๆแบบเดี๋ยวนกกระสากินปลาหมาจิ้งจอก
กินอะไรอ่ะ
หมายถึงจะคิดทำไมอ่ะอันนี้นิทานนิทานที่
อ่าอันนิทานอะไรก็เกิดขึ้นได้นกกระสายัง
พูดภาษาคนภาษาไทยละ
โอเคกูเอกเป็นเป็นสุนัขจิ้งจอกนกกระสา
ไปกินข้าวที่บ้านพี่บ้านพี่จิงจอกไหม
ได้สิได้สิ
จิ้งจอกจะพานักศึกษาไปกินอะไรอร่อยๆเพราะ
ว่าเราเป็นเพื่อนกันโอ้โห
ขอบคุณมากเลยนะ
เสียงหวานว่าเธอ
ก็เลยนะเนี่ย
ถ้าครูเอ๋เสียงเล่นละครเป็นเสียงคนดีไม่
ได้ค่ะได้จากคนแก่คนไม่ดีนะคะให้คุณอะไร
คะไม่ได้บ้าง
เขาก็โอเคนกกระสาก็ไปกินข้าวเต็มที่บ้าน
ลง
ไปในตัวเดียวหรอคะมีมีเพื่อนๆสัตว์ตัว
อื่นไหมไปแค่ตัวเดียวครับก็มีค่าสุนัข
จิ้งจอกและนกกระสาเพราะว่านักจิ้งจอกกับ
เขาอันนี้นะคะเขาก็ไปที่บ้านคือสุนัข
จิ้งจอกภาษาไม่รู้ศึกษาไม่กลัวสุนัข
จิ้งจอกกินตัวเองหรอคะเขาไม่กลัวเพราะว่า
เขาคิดแล้วไงครับว่าเป็นเพื่อนกันเพื่อน
ไม่กินเพื่อนใช่ช้าหรือหาทำไมเธอเป็นนก
ที่ดีมากมายน้องกัดหมานี่บ้านพี่
สวยจังเลย
ก็เขาก็ไปที่บ้านครับขอเขาเข้าไปในบ้าน
เนี่ยสุนัขจิ้งจอกแน่ก็เตรียมอาหารให้รัก
แต่ว่า
เขาอ่ะอาหารที่ตัว TM คือเป็นซุปเหมือน
เป็นน้ำแกง
R เหมือนมีโซ่สูบใช่
น้ำแต่ว่าเขาว่าเอาน้ำซุปน้ำแกงเนี่ยใส่
จานแบนๆแบบนี้
โอ้ว
เดี๋ยวนกกระสาปากเค้ายาวๆแล้วแหลมนะเอ๊ย
ใช่เขาก็กินได้ไหมกินไม่ได้กินไม่ได้
เพราะปกติเขากินกินแมลงกินปลากินกุ้งเล็ก
ๆ
ตลาดเขากินน่ะเขาก็เหมือนกับปากเขายามเรา
ก็จะเหมือนจะตีหนึ่งไปใช่ลองให้มันแบบ
เนี้ยก็กินบ้างโหงั้นน้ำซุปก็เป็นยังไงคะ
คุณดิมันก็
6 เหมือนกับกระเด็นออกมาแบบนี้นะครับ
เพราะว่าเวลาเค้าจะกินปากเขายาวมันก็
เหมือนกับพี่ดีจริงๆร้อนน้ำมันก็เหมือน
กับกระเด็นออก
ค่ะอ่ะสุนัขจิ้งจอกไงอร่อยมั้ยน้องนก
กระสา
ติดกินไม่ได้แต่นกกระสาเขาไม่พูดคำหรือ
มารยาทดีนะคะก็เรียบแต่ที่นี้เนี่ยเพราะ
สุนัขจิ้งจอกไม่มีปัญหาถ้าอาจารย์แบ่งเขา
ก็ใช้ลิ้นแบบกินเดือนอาจารย์ Band จาน
สงสูงสุนัขจิ้งจอกกินได้แต่จริงๆถ้าเป็น
ทรงสูงมากๆเนี่ยเขาก็กินไม่ได้นะเพราะว่า
ถ้าแหลมแหลมเล็กๆใช่ไหมเออเอาคืนสิเออ
เดี๋ยวก็อย่าเพิ่งเฉลย
เอกไม่รู้แล้วค่ะแต่พรุ่งนี้กำลังโกรธแทน
ใช่โกรธแทงอยากเอาคืนได้ไหม
ที่นี่เนี่ยสุนัขจิ้งจอกก็เจ้าเลขเพราะ
ว่าบอกว่าอ๋อไม่ชอบน้ำแกงที่ทำให้หรอหมอ
ไม่เห็นกินเอ้ยทำน้ำแกงกระจายหมดเลยทำไม
ไม่ชอบเหรอทำไมไม่บอก
แล้วเขาภาษาตอบว่ายังไงคะนกกระสาเขาก็บอก
เขาก็เงียบๆเขาก็ไม่พูดอะไรมาก
ๆเขาก็ไม่บอกว่าอ้ออ้อจานมันเดินกินไม่
ได้ค่ะเพราะว่าเขาก็ถือว่าไปบ้านคนอื่นก็
เข้าต้อนรับเราแบบไหนเราจะไปสร้างปัญหาก็
ไม่ดีใช่ไหมเฮ้ยครับเขาก็เหมือนกับพูดว่า
อ๋อจริงๆไม่ค่อยหิวเท่าไหร่
ใช่แล้วมันนกจิ้งจอกสุนัขจิ้งจอก
เขาก็บอกว่าอ๋อโอเคถ้าอย่างนั้นเดี๋ยวเขา
จะกินเองอ้าวเออเค้าเหมือนกับทำแล้วไง
ครับแล้วมันเหลือทิ้งก็เสียดายแล้วแกล้ง
สนามไม่กินเดี๋ยวฉันกินเองอ่ะเสื้อ
สุนัขจิ้งจอกแนวก็คิดในใจแล้วว่าฉันชนะ
เพราะมันจะทำให้นกกระสาหาขายขี้หน้าเสีย
หน้าครับว่าแบบมีอาหารอาหารจากจานไม่เป็น
ให้เขารู้สึกว่ากินไม่ได้ไม่ใช่กินไม่
เป็นก็เพราะว่ามันแดนรับปากเขายาวค่ะ
เขารู้สึกว่าอยู่เหนือกว่านกกระสาแล้วไหม
กู A ใช้ตะเกียบกินไม่สูบก่อนเลยนะ
กินไม่สุกครั้งแรกนี่ไหลเยิ้ม
น้องขอช้อนไม่มีท้อนน้ำตาไหลไม่กิน
จริงๆมันเป็นถ้วยเราก็ยกดื่มได้ดีคน
ญี่ปุ่นคุณนี้สมัยครูเอ๋เอาหมายคู๋เนี่ย
การยกถ้วยดื่มมันเป็นมาญาติที่ไม่เรียบ
ร้อยต้องตากอ่ะถ้ากินแล้วเป็นการกินอาหาร
ญี่ปุ่นครั้งแรกไม่รู้ว่าเอ๊ะถ้ายกซุป
แล้วไอ้เอ็กซ์ที่อยู่ไหนเนี่ยมันจะยังไง
เอาไปเปรียบกันเอาไว้แล้วก็น้ำ
ดื่มจากถ้วยไม่เป็นน่ะไหลอ๋อ
โหคนเนี่ยสนุกเท่าไร a ไม่กิน
คิมอะไรนะ
กรุงเทพบูรกรรมหล่นโอเคไม่เป็นไรเอาไปกิน
ล่ะ
แต่ตอนนี้โอเคนะคะแล้วโอเคเลยตอนนี้ถ้า
คลิปหลดก็มือแล้วค่ะหยิบ
นกกษาปณ์น่าสงสารอ้าก็ต้องกลับบ้านไปแบบ
ชิวหิวๆ
กันสุนัขจิ้งจอกดีใจแล้วเพราะว่าชนะ
เหมือนรู้สึกว่าอยู่เหนือกว่านกกระสาทำ
และนกกระสาเนี่ยอายเราก็รู้สึกแบบรู้สึก
ขายที่หน้าเขาคิดต่างๆแล้วก็จะอายไหมจริง
ๆนกกระสาอายไหมนกกระสาเนี่ยก็ไม่ได้อาย
เพราะว่าก็อยู่กันแค่ 2 ตัวนกกระสะอาด
สุนัขจิ้งจอกแต่ว่านกกระสาเนี่ยคือเขาก็
รู้รู้ว่าแน่ไม่ได้อยากเป็นเพื่อนกับฉัน
จริงๆตั้งแต่อนิจแมงอันยักษ์แรงจริงๆครับ
แรงให้อายเขาก็เลยมีความคิดว่าเดี๋ยวจะ
ต้อง
เชิญสุนัขจิ้งจอกมากินข้าวที่บ้านบ้างอ๋อ
[เพลง]
ใช่เขาก็พูดนะว่าไว้เดี๋ยวครั้งหน้าฉันจะ
ชวนเธอมากินข้าวที่บ้านนะ
สุนัขจิ้งจอกรับไหมคะอ่ะขอรับคำเชิญนะ
ครับรับๆครับตกลงจะไปไปแน่นอนเพราะว่าเขา
ก็ไม่ได้คิดอะไรในครับเพราะว่าเขาว่ารู้
ว่าเขาเนี่ยชนะแล้วครั้งนี้ก็คิดว่าเขา
ฉลาดใช่ใช่คิดว่าฉลาดกว่าเก่งกว่าฮะโอเค
ได้สิไม่คิดว่าจะมีอะไรเกิดขึ้นถ้า
ฉันชนะแล้วน้องก็สาจุกที่ทำอะไรเก่งทุก
อย่างน้ำซุปไม่ได้เอ้ยที่นี่เนี่ยเขาก็ไป
บ้านนกวันต่อไปใช่ไหมคะอายเขาก็เนี้ยคือ
นกกระสาเค้าก็มันก็เชิญเราจากนั้นเขาก็
ส่งจดหมายไปขอเชิญมาจิ้งจอกมาที่บ้านกู
เห็นนกตัวอื่นด้วย
ก็นกตัวอื่นก็เหมือนเป็นเพื่อนกับนกมาเขา
ก็อยู่เหตุการณ์ว่ามันไปใกล้กันใกล้กัน
ค่ะจะเห็นนะครับสุนัขจิ้งจอกก็ดีใจไม่รู้
ว่าจะเกิดอะไรขึ้นนะถึงก็แล้วหวัดดีน้อง
นกสา
พี่มาลี
วันนี้ทำอะไรให้พี่กินมาๆมีอาหารให้กินนก
กระสาเนี่ยก็ทำเนื้ออย่างนี้เลยให้
ตอบเจน
ว่าแต่ว่าอะไรนกกระสาเนี่ยเอาเนื้อเนี่ย
ใส่ในนี้อุ้ย
ใส่ในคณิตว่าอะไรเนี่ยมันจะอาจารย์ก็ได้
ไม่เหมือนเป็นโหลอยากคนโทรมือ
เป็นโหลเป็นขวดเลขอะไรแจกกันแท้จริงๆคง
เหตุการณ์นั้นเหมือนก็เป็นแบบเป็นใจการ
ทรงสูงอายุต้นไม้และกิ่งอ่าข้างเนื้อจะ
ใส่ไว้ข้างในได้พ่อมาเป็นเนื้อเราก็เอา
เป็นหันเป็นชิ้น size  M ค่ะเนี่ยมันก็
อยู่ตรงตรงเนี้ยตรงข้างล่างใช่ตรงข้าง
ล่างตรงนี้นะค่ะนี่เนี่ย
อายอย่างเนี้ยครับก็เห็นแปลว่านกกระสา
เนี่ยก็กินได้ง่ายๆเลยคือ
จะใช่
อ๋อนกกระสาปากยาวแล้วก็ปากเล็กใช่เอาปาก
ต้องไปแล้วก็คีบเนื้อแล้วก็ขึ้นมาก็กิน
ใช่ก็กินไม่มีปัญหาน้ำมาถึงจะออกนะคะมา
จิ้งจอกทีมไม่ได้ก็ก็ได้แค่เอาลิ้นเนี่ย
เรียนอาเมเรียตรงขอบของ
ถ้วยอันนี้
คู่เอกเป็นเด็กน่ะกูอีกก็จะถามว่าอะไรรู้
ไหมคะถ้าไม่มาถึงจองไม่ยกเคอ่ะ
เพราะว่าเห็นมีมือจับข้างหน้าเขาก็คงไม่
คิดว่าเวลากินข้าวเหนียวมันยกถ้วยยกจาน
ขึ้นได้ไงครับ
ใช่เหมือนกันเมื่อกี้ที่ว่าเขากินข้าว
เนี่ยเขาก็เหมือนกับจับแต่ว่าไม่ได้ยก
ถ้วยก็คือจะ
แล้วก็นี้เฮีย
ธรรมชาติมาเขาจะไม่ยกนะคะเขาจะไม่ยกขึ้น
ค่ะอันนี้ก็เหมือนกันก็เห็นไหมว่าสุนัข
จิ้งจอกหน้าตาแบบเคลียร์แต่เหรอกินยังไง
มันให้กิน
โอโห้แล้วสุนัขจิ้งจอกเป็นยังไงคะที่สุด
ในทิศตอบไม่ใช่ตกใจแล้วก็ก็อยากกินแต่กิน
ไม่ได้เพราะว่าหมอไม่ใช่มั้ยใช่หอมแต่ทำ
อะไรไม่ได้นอกจากเลียแค่ข้างนอก
แล้ว
นกกระสาบอกว่ายังไงคะนกกระสาเนี่ยก็เห็น
แล้วก็พูดเลยว่าชั้นน่ะจะไม่ขอโทษหรอกนะ
ที่เธอกินไม่ได้อุ้ย
แล้วก็จะที่เรียบร้อยร้ายนะเธอร้ายสายน้ำ
ไม่ไม่ธรรมดาชาติเอกก็นึกว่ารกษาจะบอกว่า
โอเคไม่เป็นไรเดี๋ยวคีบให้
ตอนนี้ก็สารู้ไงครับว่าครั้งที่แล้วเนี่ย
สุนัขตอบแปลงเขาเขาก็เลยแกล้งกลับค่าชาย
เขาก็บอกว่าฉันจะไม่ขอโทษนะเพราะครั้งที่
แล้วอ่ะแต่เธอก็ทำเหมือนกับที่ฉันทำแบบ
นี้อ๋อ
โอเคคือกฎก็เหมือนกับว่าเอ่อเชิญไปที่
บ้านพร้าวสุนัขจิ้งจอกก็มีจานแบบที่สุนัข
จิ้งจอกกินได้แต่ไม่คิดว่านกกระสาอังกฤษ
ได้ไหม
ฉะนั้นเมื่อสุนัขจิ้งจอกมาบ้านนกกระสาก็
ต้องใช้วัฒนธรรมบ้านนกกระสาขึ้นกินในโถตี
ในใจกันนะคะจะนะแน่เธอก็ต้องทำให้ได้
เหมือนค่ะ
เพราะว่าเธอให้ฉันทำเหมือนเธอ
ราชการจิงจอกรู้สึกอะไรคะก็รู้สึกว่าแท้
ฮ่าๆๆไม่ใช่ๆนกกระสาหัวเราะมั้ยลบภาษา
หัวเราะไหมเขาก็ไม่ได้หัวเราะนางแต่เขา
คิดว่าเหมือนกับแกล้มก็เรียงอย่าคิดว่า
ฉันจะไม่รู้ขาดเป็นบทเรียนให้สุนัข
จิ้งจอก
แล้วสุนัขจิ้งจอกดีขึ้นไหมอ่ะตอนจบเนี่ย
ต้องจบดีขึ้นไหม
หวังว่าจะดีขึ้นเพราะหวังว่านะคะให้พ่อ
สุนัขจิ้งจอกแน่ก็กลับบ้านไปเราก็คิดว่า
แพ้
โดนนกกระสาเนี่ยแกล้งกลับเข้าเด็คเอาคืน
อื่นชายเอาคือ
จริงๆถ้าถ้ามองในแง่อ่ะไม่ดีก็คือเอาคือ
เลยแกล้งกลับแต่ถ้ามองอีกมุมหนึ่งนกกระสา
อยากจะสอนสุนัขจิ้งจอกว่าอยากจะทำไม่ดี
กับคนอื่นไม่ใช่ๆอื่นเขาไม่รู้แล้วถ้า
เกิดโดนทำบ้างจะรู้สึกอย่างไรช้าใช่ครับ
อันนี้เนี่ยก็จะเป็นขอนิทานว่าเรื่องนี้
เนี่ยสอนให้รู้ว่าถ้าทำไม่ดีกับใครเนี่ย
อย่าว่าเขาจะไม่รู้หรือหรือเขาอาจจะอดทน
อยู่ใช่แล้วเขาอาจจะเอาคืนทีหลังได้ถ้า
มันไม่ดีกับใครไว้ก็เตรียมตัวว่าจะโดน
สิ่งไม่ดีนั้นอ่ะ
กลับมาบ้างนะคะใกล้ๆเอ๋อ่ะพี่เอ๋บอกว่า
มันเหมือนกับเป็นมุมที่ปกติบางคนก็คือจะ
ยอมไม่เป็นไรคนที่ชอบทำไม่ดีกับคนอื่นก็
จะไม่รู้สึกอะไรก็ตัวเองอ่ะไม่เคยโดนเอา
คืนเช้านะคะนกกระสานะคงอยากจะสอนว่าอาไอ้
ความรู้สึกที่คนอื่นรู้สึกเนี่ยมันเป็น
ยังไงคุณต้องรู้สึกบ้างจะได้หยุดทำไม่ดี
กับคนอื่นอย่ามัวแต่คิดเอาชนะฉันจะต้อง
ชนะฉันเก่งซึ่งบางเรื่องไอ้ความเก่งบาง
เรื่องมันแต่มันไม่ใช่ความเก่งที่ดีอ่ะ
พี่เก่งผิดๆอย่าทำ
[เพลง]
อะไรครับก็เป็นนิทานของวันนี้เกี่ยวกับนก
กระสาแลนด์หมายถึงจอกสูงว่า
จบแล้วคุยไปนอนได้แล้วใช่ไหมคะง่วงแล้ว
ใช่ไหมครับ
ตอนนี้
วันนี้ทำไมฟังนิทานรถตื่น
แล้วฟังแล้วง่วงนอนอาทินี้ฟังก็ตื่นเลย
ตื่น
เร็วต้องไปแล้วเพราะเวลาหมดแล้วว่าโอเค
ค่ะแล้วก็เป็นใหม่คลิปหน้าค่ะคุณนิได้
โอเคครับไว้พบกันใหม่ครับสวัสดีครับ
สวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ